uh ben slater joins us now he is also
the chairman of the nomad concepts group
and he is with us now
from doha ben
great to have you on the program this
morning um just wondering how you're
feeling to be out of afghanistan
uh good morning uh yes um obviously it's
uh it's it's it's it's nice to obviously
be out and um
obviously in qatar and uh safe and well
how were you treated um by the taliban
well clearly there was going to there
was considerable concern
about risks to your own personal safety
i'm just wondering how you found
ahead the past few weeks
uh okay i mean obviously uh as you're
probably aware i've been
with them for uh well as of yesterday
for approximately five weeks um so
actually uh about five weeks in total so
the first two weeks um
uh being honest was uh not not too
pleasant uh so basically what happened
was is that uh when i was obviously
initially arrested um and uh i was we
was held in torque um for three days in
a jail there's like a concrete cell
um basically just sitting on the floor
um and that was obviously um in in in
isolation and captivity
for three days there where the initial
interrogation started
um and then basically from there i was
moved into a detention prison as uh jail
um which was obviously used for
interrogation and uh of uh
more of the exotic uh kind of uh you
know criminals or people that you know
needed those facilities to be detained
so i was there for uh two weeks and that
those two weeks were pretty pretty bad
conditions um
what it was is that they'd obviously
picked up on the fact that i was i was
ex-military and naturally that led to
them thinking that i was obviously uh
you know like a james bond type
character basically um so as soon as
that was um
mentioned uh that was possibly mi or mi5
uh basically i lost a lot of my rights i
lost a lot of my um you know sort of
uh sort of dignity basically for a
couple of weeks so there was a bit of
obviously um you know there was a few um
aggressive actions uh the the jail cell
was basically on a par
with uh like uh what they kept
mentioning guantanamo bay uh the
conditions are quite similar uh it was
very hot it was very crowded uh and it
was very very unusual for me to be in
that situation because
you know um
it was very much like that for two weeks
uh completely isolated no communication
uh you know bag over the head handcuffs
moved around you know obviously a couple
of uh you know a couple of let's just
say uh beatings uh let's just be honest
okay everyone's aware of it someone's
gonna say it um and then of course then
there was the interview phases getting
moved around
and obviously
it was unusual for me because obviously
the situation uh was
at that point for me pretty dire because
obviously i knew that this wasn't good
and uh there was no way i could get any
communication out i was in
the same uh
jail as basically you know unfortunately
there was uh is in there there was daesh
in there there was obviously some pretty
nasty criminals in there but obviously
the taliban were also processing so for
me it was a really unusual environment
to be in um then after the uh the two
weeks of that uh basically
uh uh the the actual the director dr
bashir uh the main sort of head in the
jalalabad uh sort of uh area covering
the nangarhar province uh which talk and
falls under uh he obviously uh
he realized that yes obviously i was
ex-military and yes i was obviously
evacuating uh afghan women
out of the country uh my staff
mainly in their families
and basically but he did a determined
that i wasn't what he initially thought
i was so after that two week points
which was useful i suspect ben which was
really which was incredibly useful and
and then the the the treatment change i
i have to ask though you you you came
out of afghanistan i think on the same
plane that sir simon gas was on the the
uk's hybrid representative to
afghanistan i mean were they there
to negotiate your release or had that
already been secured agreed
before they spoke to the taliban
leadership
okay i mean look um i'd like to say
obviously the the the home office and
the scdo and obviously the uk government
and the agencies involved uh it's been
absolutely fantastic i mean obviously
now i'm getting aware of what was
actually done so basically uh in regards
to simon gas and the uh deputy
ambassador or the ambassador now in
exile um we're basically there obviously
having meetings about the uh the
delegation come in
uh regarding the humanitarian issues and
maybe how
there could be possible engagement in
the future to help the afghan people
okay
and basically i think obviously they
took the opportunity
uh because i was there obviously when
they come in i think i was used not used
i would say i was like a trojan horse to
maybe start that dialogue and to say
like oh can you also release uh benjamin
so that was why it was all very quick
for me because
um not only was the the the
british ambassador has done a fantastic
job in uh qatar doha
and obviously simon bass and the deputy
ambassador in
exile for afghanistan
and the home office also the british
high commissioner in uh and the
consulate
team had put a very creative plan in
place to get me to islamabad as well so
there was basically two
embassies and the home office and
everyone was working as a collective and
i must admit when i arrived i was very
surprised i was very rushed i didn't
know what was happening i didn't even
know where i was going at that point and
obviously to see
simon bass and martin the um the the
ambassador in exile that was obviously
having the negotiations obviously some
of it was about me and some of it was
about the massive humanitarian issues
that are ongoing ben
we're really pushed for time i just want
to squeeze in a quick question you it's
great that you have made it on we're
very very pleased on your behalf and
indeed for for your friends and family
but one of those left behind you're a
former serviceman yourself you
understand the role that the
interpreters played on the ground in
afghanistan for us there are still lots
of them waiting to come out of the
country
yeah i mean there's obviously a lot of
people still there um obviously i am
having beginning dialogue with multiple
countries including the uk to obviously
organize visas
and to obviously get some more of these
at risk out but they're still in so
obviously there was a bit of
miscommunication when i was initially
arrested obviously
we still managed to get 112 people out
okay so we were very successful
now we are um trying to basically
um organize uh visas through the email
system through various governments we're
hoping the uk canada usa australia and
the european countries do
kindly get in touch or i can engage them
and maybe get a few from each country
and then i can finish off the amount
that are left behind uh they're
currently obviously keeping a low
profile and they are
they're informing me every day
ben i'm so sorry that we have to leave
it there but as said really good to have
you out of the country and and hope you
continue to be well thanks for joining
us thank you so much